meet Mo it's important to try your best
and ask for help if you need it the
latest artificial intelligence consumer
Gadget meant for children so this robot
runs off of AI yes how so what is it
supposed to do so it self initiates
conversations and experiences with the
child it can start a conversation like
hey how was the day in school what did
you learn today that's what the robot
will ask the child exactly it will take
the child on a path which just
personalized based on the interests and
and the weaknesses where the child says
that okay I'm scared of mathematics the
robot will have a healthy conversation
trying to motivate the child to deal
with math problems it's an AI system
it's not meant to replace a teacher
friend parent in the life of the child
can I ask any question 100% okay I'm
going to pretend I'm a child talking to
Mo hello
Mo should I eat my
vegetables yes you should eat vegetables
because they are good for your health
and provide important nutrients that
your body needs say we want to go on
this when could we have a sample the
global toy industry is jumping into AI
you could talk about the deal and
everything that children are usually
fast adopters of new technologies this
next Generation call them gen Alpha will
be the AI generation they will not know
life without an AI chatbot they're a lot
of fun I'm just loving the leap forward
in the conversational aspect but AI
embedded in toys has its dangers mostly
relating to privacy and personal
information particularly sensitive when
it comes to children people who are
thinking about Ai and who are concerned
about it should really think about it as
a tool and any tool you would want to
use ethically when does it with Mo the
company says the data collected is kept
within the device and not uploaded to a
cloud where it could be exploited a
feature is in the works to alert parents
if the robot detects the child is in
danger or is contemplating violence AI
robots were once considered science
fiction but MO is proving it's now
reality the company plans to sell 1
million robots by years's end Gabriel
zando Al jazer New
York make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer